and then the final thing i want to talk
about is uh muscle damage
um
and and eccentric training in particular
but
uh more more just like mitigation of
muscle damage in general
uh so i wrote an article titled does
eccentric training always cause more
muscle damage the title of the article i
was reviewing was uh eccentric exercise
per se does not affect muscle damage
biomarkers early and late phase
adaptations
uh
by a name i don't feel like trying to
pronounce uh
out of respect
you want to possibly disrespect them by
no i'm gonna i'm gonna roll the dice
margaret telus maybe
anyway
uh so this study was pretty
straightforward they took a group of
untrained individuals uh split them in
half randomized them into groups and had
them do isokinetic knee extensions once
once per week
for 10 weeks
and all of these training sessions were
just five sets of 15 maximal repetitions
and one group did five sets of 15
maximal concentric reps so you know
basically you set up the dynamometer to
only move at a slow angular velocity and
you just say kick kick kick kick kick
kick as hard as you possibly can for
five sets of 15
concentric only and then the other group
did eccentric only reps so again you set
the dynamometer at a slow angular
velocity and it's going to flex your
knee and what you're trying to do is
resist it with as much force as possible
so over the 10 weeks the researchers
monitored
quite a few
indirect markers of muscle damage so
they assessed pain-free range of motion
delayed onset muscle soreness isometric
peak torque at 90 degrees of knee
flexion concentric peak torque eccentric
peak torque creatine kinase levels uh
which is a
indirect marker of muscle damage and c
reactive protein levels which is a
marker of inflammation
they assessed all of those things for a
couple of days after each training
session throughout the entire 10-week
protocol
uh
and what they found is that for the
first couple of training sessions
they found exactly what you would expect
the eccentric training caused way more
muscle damage than the concentric
training for
every marker of muscle damage and
performance they looked at so
pain-free range of motion was decreased
to a greater extent delayed onset muscle
soreness was greater
isometric torque decreased to a greater
extent concentric torque decreased to a
greater extent eccentric torque
decreased to a greater extent larger
elevations in creatine kinase levels and
larger elevations in c reactive protein
levels so for the first three weeks of
training
every single one of those markers
indicated greater muscle damage for
eccentric training than constant than
concentric training
from weeks four to seven it was kind of
a transitional period where some of
those indirect markers of muscle damage
kind of dropped out of showing a
difference between
uh exercise protocols so
like on week four
most of the markers still suggested more
muscle damage with eccentric training
but now concentric peak torque changes
post training they didn't differ between
groups anymore by week six you're no
longer seeing differences in soreness
isometric peak torque concentric peak
torque and c-reactive protein and then
uh from weeks
uh eight to ten you basically weren't
seeing differences between exercise
protocols at all um
there was no indication that the
eccentric only training was
still causing more muscle damage than
the concentric only training
so
uh i i think that this was a pretty
powerful illustration
that uh when we talk about the repeated
bouts effect and the ability of muscles
to
protect themselves and become more
resilient against muscle damage over
time uh kind of a question there is like
to what extent can those adaptations
occur like what
what can the muscles kind of on the
upper end of things protect themselves
against to mitigate muscle damage
and this study suggests to me that they
can uh
that that functionally there's limitless
capacity and the reason i say that is
like
you know the practical question is
can the repeated bout effect occur to
such an extent that normal resistance
training no longer causes really any
significant level of muscle damage and
if they were finding
uh basically no indication that muscle
damage was occurring by
the end of 10 weeks in this study with
that eccentric training protocol
that suggests to me that you can
absolutely get to the point where
virtually no muscle damage is occurring
with just normal training the reason i
say that is this eccentric training
protocol was
it's hard to overstate how much more
brutal it was than anything that anyone
would ever do in the gym for
the purpose of just like normal
resistance training so you hear five
sets of 15 and you think like oh that's
uh that's kind of high volume work i
think i'd be a little sore from that
five sets of 15 is not the same thing as
five sets of 15 maximal eccentric reps
um
i mean like just one set of 15 maximal
eccentric reps would would probably uh
[ __ ] most people
no matter how well trained you are if
you did
like the first week of the eccentric
training protocol here i promise you you
would be wrecked for three or four days
like that's
that's an enormous amount of eccentric
stress so if the subjects could fully
kind of accommodate that after just 10
weeks of training which uh was just 10
sessions of training because they were
only training once per week
uh that suggests that within kind of
practical boundaries
uh the repeated bout effect is is
sufficient to
to probably mitigate virtually all
muscle damage that occurs and so um
i think that this is very relevant
for people who who wonder like hey man
i've been training consistently for a
while i used to get kind of sore after
training i don't really get sore anymore
is that a sign that something is wrong
probably not um
soreness significantly mitigating and
and perhaps going away completely over
time that's a very normal outcome um
and and it's perfectly fine there's no
strong evidence that soreness is
particularly predictive of training
outcomes so
um you know that that is a normal thing
to expect and you shouldn't be concerned
about it uh conversely you may be
wondering like hey if the subjects here
in this study
were basically mitigating all muscle
damage after 10 weeks of training why do
i still get sore if i've been training
consistently for a while
and i think probably the main
contributor is just exercise variety or
training variety you know you're
changing rep ranges you're changing
exercise you're maybe changing range of
motion and how you're executing reps etc
um
and repeated bout effect related
adaptations are both general and
specific so
if you are
someone who's reasonably well trained in
a particular style of training and you
do
a workout with a different style of
training
you you have some general protective
adaptations such that
you will probably be less sore following
that training session than a completely
untrained person would be
but uh the adaptations are specific to
some degree so you know you don't you
don't have a
full muscle damage resistance against
all things that could possibly cause
muscle damage so
a key component of this study was
subjects did do the exact same exercise
protocol every time it was five sets of
15 maximal eccentric knee extensions
at a fixed angular velocity
through a fixed range of motion so once
you start changing variables around
you are probably still causing some
muscle damage
due to
some degree of novelty and variety in
your training so you know it's
it's reasonable to expect some degree of
soreness moving forward especially if
training variables are shifting but it's
also very reasonable to expect
very very substantial decreases in
muscle soreness perhaps going away
entirely those are both
very very normal
outcomes of training and neither of them
suggest that anything
bad is going on so if you've if you've
ever worried about anything related to
soreness am i not getting sore enough am
i getting too sore it's probably fine
everything's fine you don't need to
worry about it
um
and then the last thing i want i kind of
wanted to draw out of this study
is i think that these findings are
relevant to the idea of training to
failure
so um
[Music]
one of the ideas that i think people
have falsely gotten about me
uh is that i'm against training to
failure that i that i'm an anti-failure
crusader
um
and like i'm just i'm not uh so i have
argued multiple times
and will continue to do so that you
don't need to train to failure
every set to maximize the per set
hypertrophy outcomes
if you're
acquainted with the quote unquote
effective reps model of hypertrophy i've
argued against that i i don't think that
the evidence substantiates it and i
think that there's a pretty reasonable
amount of evidence against it
um
but the the statement of i don't think
you need to go to failure all the time
to maximize hypertrophy is not the same
as i am against training to failure and
in fact
i do most of my training to failure um
not for squat bench deadlift but for
basically everything else
largely because i think it idiot proves
training um
like you know i don't want to have to
think about my level of effort when i'm
exercising
um
you know i
i i think if i'm
trying to think like okay what is the
perfect sub-maximal amount of effort to
exert
to minimize the fatigue accumulated in
this set but maximize the hypertrophic
adaptation in this set i don't know some
people maybe are into that i'm [ __ ]
not uh
like i'm gonna think about it a little
bit for my core lifts for everything
else i just want to turn my brain off
and lift stuff like i like lifting stuff
and making myself tired that's
those are some of the things i love
about training um
so i just don't want to have to think
about it too too hard i think that
training to failure largely idiot proofs
your training and when i'm training i am
an idiot
um now is that
is that failure failure or is it like
volitional failure without
digging into like my absolute top gear
that's like failure failure okay um
it depends on the lift uh
like
i don't like being pinned by squats
um
interesting yeah it's it's not my
favorite thing but for
i don't know like dumbbell press i'm
just going to press until like i can't
actually get the weights up anymore and
then i say oh well i guess i'm done no
more reps yeah uh tricep extensions same
thing just keep going once i can't lock
it out you know i'm just going to bring
the bar to my chest close script press
it up so yeah i mean like failure
failure um
so yeah
and one of the
because i i just want to say i went back
into your lifting videos and when
you claimed to go to failure i actually
found that you had seven reps left in
the tank
we're not we're not doing this
[Laughter]
oh man um
yeah
so
uh
so people who are
like actually
anti-failure training
the the biggest argument they'll bring
up is that there's there's plenty of
research it's not even worth citing
individual studies there is a
robust and flourishing body of evidence
uh showing
that when you train to failure it causes
uh larger decrements in performance pre
to post training and uh requires longer
to recover from an exercise session than
doing kind of uh
non-failure training that's equated for
reps or total volume load and so you
know people will argue that like the
cost benefit calculus doesn't make sense
here if you can get just as much muscle
growth not training to failure
but when you train to failure
you're causing more fatigue you're
taking longer to recover and you're not
really getting anything in return
that constitutes a strong reason to not
go to failure in training and to
advocate against really ever training to
failure
but i don't go that far and and some of
the findings from this study and you
know prior to the study being published
just my own experience constituted
reasons why i don't necessarily buy that
argument um
so you know if people can acclimate to
five sets of 15 of maximal eccentric
reps i think people can [ __ ]
acclimate to training to failure um
such that like if you do
if you do a study in in you
this kind of drifts off your point you
made about muscle protein synthesis
research if you put people through
unaccustomed exercise they're not used
to it's causing a lot of muscle damage
maybe mps isn't necessarily
representative i think the same thing
applies to
research looking at how different
training variables impact muscle damage
and fatigue and recovery from training
where if you're putting someone through
an unaccustomed exercise protocol
their post exercise response to that may
not necessarily be representative of how
their post exercise response would look
if they trained in that manner for a
matter of weeks or months and and that's
been my experience with uh with failure
training like if i've been doing a
highly specific block of powerlifting
stuff with really no accessory work um
and not doing basically any training to
failure then like you know when i when i
toss in some skull crushers and just
like really push myself to the limits my
triceps are gonna be [ __ ] for three or
four days after that but then if i do it
for like
three weeks four weeks or something like
that
my triceps don't get sore anymore and
they don't they don't really seem to be
any more fatigued post-training than
they would be if i didn't go to failure
so i i think that this study indirectly
supports that observation that you know
most things that might cause more muscle
damage than other things and in this
case i'm talking about training to
failure i think if you do those things
whatever they are
for
not even that extended of a period of
time but like you know four five six
seven eight workouts um
i think eventually your body just adapts
to it you acclimate it no longer causes
that much additional muscle damage or
fatigue and it's fine so
uh i and i i could just be kind of
playing into my own confirmation biases
here because
brother you're never going to get me to
to estimate reps in reserve on a set of
rear delt flies i'm never gonna do it
like that's always going to failure uh
and
you know if i'm wrong if that's
sub-optimal i don't [ __ ] care because
i i am never going to tell you my rpe
for a set of of delt raises it's always
10 it's only ever going to be 10. i'm
not gonna stop that shy of failure and
you can't make me